um so welcome everyone to
our uh weekly d mice research conference
and as
sometimes happens when um we don't have
a
um speaker we
pull in the clinical informatics journal
club that normally
takes place um on thursdays
among the clinical informatics fellows
although actually this topic is actually
one that
would hopefully um be of some interest
um
you know across the the bcb hcin
um divide of the uh department
um and um um i had actually read this
article before
i was told that eric wanted to present
it and i actually thought it was
interesting because i also
as many of you know have an interest in
access and retrieval of information of
clinical information
um so um uh
uh just uh most of you probably all of
you know eric but just uh briefly
um he is one of our clinical informatics
fellows
which means that he's a physician he
went to
medical school at san juan batista
school of medicine
and then did a residency in family
medicine at shasta community health
center
down the road in reading california he
then
joined our program as a clinical
informatics
fellow and so he is going to
present to us today um
an overview and lead some discussion on
this
uh article that was published in jmer
recently
so take it away eric
thanks bill so yeah he mentioned that uh
bill just mentioned that this might be
of some interest to
some of the biomedical folks which i
i certainly hope that will bring some
interesting perspectives to the
discussion
so this paper is called info buttons for
genomic medicine
requirements and barriers
it's a multi-institutional group of
authors
so what what the the
the point the objective of this study
was really to look at barriers to
implementation
of free and open source software
called foss in health information
technology
what is that what most of you probably
know but foss is free and open source
software
so free as in freedom
anyone's freely licensed to use it copy
study or change it in any way
an open source that means the source
code is publicly available for any use
so generally free and open source are
one in the same
there it's mainly a philosophical
difference
so that's why we kind of use the term
foss to encompass all of that
does not mean that it has no cost
you have a license so you can do
whatever you want with the software
but but there's there is a cost there's
a cost of implementation
there's a cost of support so there there
is money
involved with implementing free software
and then you might also see this term
floss that means
free libre and open source software
so that word is borrowed from latin
because
the english word free can mean either
free is in freedom or free as in
i have to pay for this so
that word is used to make the
distinction so you might see this this
term that some people prefer
so here are some barriers to adoption
identified by a study
in 2018 and they're generally
categorized into four main groups
there's individual barriers
environmental barriers technological
barriers
and organizational barriers
so in health and biomedical informatics
both technical and non-technical
considerations are important
and there's all kinds of different
infrastructure
layers and settings so there may be
different
barriers in these different places and
then
another thing pointed out by the authors
was that the medical specialties
may not always have an impact but they
should be considered and there aren't
any
identified impacts of medical
specialties at this point but
it's just kind of a cautionary point
so this uh this project
was using info buttons as a as a vehicle
to study
the implementation of this software so
what info buttons are
are like a form of passive clinical
decision support
so you have a essentially a link
inside your ehr
where you can get information that you
wanted
easily
so so this helps helps
is that m
thanks okay um so this makes it easier
for providers to access the information
they need at the point of care
i got some info on this from the ohsu
hosted
clinical informatics info wiki
so the methods for this study was
there's a 20 question
web based survey this was developed by
the
info button work group of the emerge
consortium and they actually
developed and hosted one of the one of
the
products we'll look at and this was made
this survey was made to assess
three info button related technologies
for genetic and genomic medicine
so the first one is the clingen ehr
toolkit
it's built upon the open info button
system
it looks people look you can look up
genes in here and such
there's docubuild which is a web app
and you can basically create and share
stuff
inside ehrs and that's
customizable in that way
and there's um excuse me
my results.org and this is
a tool designed for
for patients to be able to interpret
their
their results whether it's you know lab
tests or
genes or whatever that may be
so the survey was designed with there
there were
open-ended there's a option for
respondents to have open-ended responses
so they collected information about
their background their familiarity with
info buttons
opinions on the utility of these three
systems
and then the meat of it is the perceived
barriers to adoption at their
institution
and they were presented a list of
barriers
uh based on the consolidated framework
for implementation research so this is a
more generalized
um barriers to adoption
paradigm that were presented
the the questions were it wasn't a
multiple choice question per se but
the respondents were asked to consider
these barriers
so the the authors selected a sample
based on convenience and then they got
recommendations from
uh the people they invited
to expand their sampling size
so they limited it to participants in
a consortium-driven initiative focusing
on
implementing genomic medicine
and then within those consortiums they
targeted
any groups that focused on informatics
ehr integration or
uh the return of clinical genomics
results
if if possible as those folks were
would were believed to have uh relevant
insight on on this question in
particular
so here are the consortia that received
infide
invitations and then any specific
working groups in there
so and they they sent out the
invitations in
february 2017 that's when they started
doing that
eric we lost your sound
can you hear me now yes oh okay yes
yeah all right so
anyway you can read this for yourself
close to all responses in september
2017.
so there were there were open-ended
responses
about the perceived barriers and they
the
authors used qualitative methods to
identify the relevant themes
two of the authors use some open coding
and they went through and
and tagged these responses as either
the sort of predefined cfir barriers
or they made a new code to
make it identify a new barrier if they
thought that was
appropriate um
there was a significant amount of time
that had gone by since
this survey closed and
so there's a question did these barriers
change in any in any way since then is
there a way to
you know could this be more relevant now
or less relevant now than it was at the
time
so the authors did a critical review and
they just did this via email
um with no blinding just just to
determine
what what was the change to these
barriers
and and they they largely found that
there
there was not um significant change
so they got 81 responses to their survey
and out of those
um 30 percent were considered to be
complete
and they included those so um
incomplete surveys just weren't weren't
done all the way or they got some
responses that contained no
answers within the system market is
complete but they
didn't have anything in there
and from these respondents were from
16 this is a you know this is not an
exclusive
these are not exclusive categories but
there was 16
academic medical centers or affiliated
health systems that had representatives
who
responded to health information
technology vendors
um four respondents were
at institutions that were affiliated
with
the development of the systems that were
surveyed specifically
and 13 respondents self
declared their involvement in an
informatics or
hit work group
so here are the institution names and a
number of respondents
from each institution a couple of places
had
two responses respondents but most had
only one
so 66.7
of the respondents said they were
knowledgeable about info buttons in
general but
less so about the specific tools
most of them were not using these tools
at all at the time of the survey
and the highest usage of these tools was
at the institutions in which
they were developed which is
unsurprising
and as you can see um
eight respondents said that there were
info buttons
available at their institution
that's one-third and then three of them
use it for genomic medicine
so what were the perceived barriers
out of the the list from cfir
there was one that was not rated by
anyone as a potential issue
and that was poor design quality and
packaging
didn't come in didn't come into play
so these are the cfir
barriers that that were identified these
are the
um so we have lack of adaptability
lack of trial ability not clearly better
than alternatives
too complex lack of evidence strength
and quality
lack of a legitimate source or
too costly
those were the ones that were identified
and then through the qualitative
analysis
the authors identified six additional
barriers that
they thought deserved consideration and
they said that three of them had only
one supporting quote but they did see
them as broadly applicable
so they they warranted their own
their own tag
so the additional perceived barriers are
not an institutional priority
lack of demand lack
of ehr integration lack of coded data
limited institutional resources and
provider workflow issues so the most uh
the most common commonly cited ones we
will
discuss in a little more depth in a
minute
so the yeah the critical review that the
authors performed noted that
there have been technical and content
improvements to all three of these
systems
since the survey and in particular the
adaptability trial ability and
complexity
[Music]
of these systems is largely unchanged
since then
um there are new alternatives so there
are other competing systems that are
available now that weren't at the time
and institutional priorities um
are different and they continue to
change so
that's another thing that that may have
changed is that
um some some folks may have gotten more
support from leadership at their
institutions to
to do projects with genetic and genomic
medicine
and other people are still facing the
same
challenges they were before and that's
going to continue to
to evolve
so there were 14 perceived barriers in
total
and notably none of these are unique
to genomic medicine one and one in
particular that's a particular challenge
is this lack of coded data
because results are often in pdf
documents pdf form which can't
effectively be parsed
by the by the systems so that's
faced often in genomics
but because these are not um unique
barriers there are some existing models
that can be leveraged
to to aid in adoption there
you know of course there are specific
considerations within healthcare and
then
also even more specifically to genetic
and genomic medicine
so the the these barriers are uh we'll
talk about each of the barriers
more or less in order of the um
the amount of times they were cited um
and we won't mention every single one
but the discussion also
will sort of combine some of the
barriers
into one discussion point when when the
recommendations on how to address them
are
more or less along the same lines
so first of all there's a lack of
adaptability
and um
there's a there's quite a difference in
the culture
around the delivery of care and
engagement with patients engagement with
clinicians
at different healthcare institutions um
which is which is one of the reasons
the the authors think this might be
so important to the respondents and then
also the the implementation of genetics
and genomic medicine
varies at all at all these institutions
as well
so the there is some
adaptability the clingen toolkit and
docubuild
allow you to basically choose where
um where you're go which information
resources you're going to pull your
your results from
however something that hasn't really
been taken into account by any of these
projects is
like the way that the results are
formatted and displayed so basically
you know institutional branding they
can't really do that
and that might be important to some of
these places and it's
not an option with with this stuff so
there was not really a recommendation
provided by the authors to address this
barrier but
um it seems like allowing
customizable uh branding by institutions
might
lower this barrier
and then we have a couple of them here
together not an institutional priority
and lack of demand so you know obviously
healthcare institutions have
lots of competing priorities and they
can't take them on all
at the same time
so one thing suggested is you know use
careful planning and
choose a leader or a champion for
genetics and genomic medicine
that seems pretty clear
and and then you know that the same
thing that
that we hear with with every project at
every institution you have to
clearly uh describe the benefits
and to to the practicing clinicians so
you have to get
you know buy-in from your stakeholders
it's a
pretty standard approach so um you can
you can get leadership but if you don't
have the people in the trenches
um supporting the project it's not going
to work and
this applies to every it project or
pretty much any institutional project
so there was a lack of trial ability
so these these uh products do have
publicly available trials so you can go
and try them out however
um different institutions require
customizations in their implementation
of this
and and there's not a ability to
try that out and they also can't use it
in their actual
clinical workflow so um that's that's
that sort of trial is limited in its
utility
so a way to address this barrier is
to for the developers of the of the
software they need to
identify their partners and then
they actually need to support them in
their implementation
of the software and they need to to make
sure they have the resources to do that
so that's obviously a a big ask but
um you know without the ability to
really see how these
these uh products work in practice
a lot of institutions are going to be
hesitant to
you know put the resources towards
implementing them
so not clearly better than alternatives
so some of these tools if they are truly
novel it is
it's difficult for the uh
the potential adopters to identify the
benefits of them
be in the brief time that they have to
actually evaluate them
so the proposed solution to this is
essentially
to do market research and develop
marketing material
and to um to reference the other
competing existing systems that that do
similar things
[Music]
this kind of goes back to
it almost to the institutional support
lack of demand i mean
it's all about communication you know
what what can
what can this stuff do for you you have
to clearly explain it
um and you have to get you know not just
the technical people on board with it
so there's a there's a complaint that
it's too complex
and so the the the
the initial thought is the user
interface but that's not
really the consideration that um is
is at the top here it's the
implementation that that is considered
to be complex and that's the case in
just about
just about every one of these uh you
know
organizational i.t projects the
implementation is
is always complex but the way to address
it is
with the quality of the documentation
so you know the the developers need
documentation that
has been uh you know tried out
and they've verified they've used their
own documentation
and so if you know if we go back to the
previous barrier
about supporting partners in
implementation they need to
have instructions that they can follow
along with to make sure they work
but then you know outside of the control
of any any
um foss developers would be the
i.t culture and the internal governance
and approval process at the institution
um that that obviously
plays a huge role in the the perception
of how much resources
these projects will take up
and then there's a concern about the
lack of evidence strength
and quality and also lack of a
legitimate source
so in in clinical settings in healthcare
um they demand
quality and robustness in the tools
they're using because
you know we're talking about people's
lives and significant
liability as well so
oftentimes popularity is equated with
quality so they
you look around say how many other
institutions are using this product and
if no one else is using it
you're not going to be the first one
so one way to address this is
the legitimate legitimacy of the
evidence of the the information
from these resources has to be clearly
presented
and this is in addition to the technical
quality of the
actual tool and
this is a continuing to evolve in
genetics and genomic medicine
and like the clingen tool for example
now at this point has
clearly presented sources and links
there
and they they can show how to attribute
it so
this is this is improving
and another complaint is the lack of ehr
integration this is a
this is another very tough problem
because ehr systems
are not free in open source they and
so they're usually like a black box
developers
simply cannot they don't have access
to ehrs it's you know essentially if
if you are not an employee of the of the
institution
utilizing the ehr if you're not a
uh clinician you you know you just won't
you won't get to see
what you're working with and so the the
integration points
of where these info buttons can be
placed or
or how the product actually interfaces
with the ehr when it faces the user is
inconsistent there's different
rules with different ehrs and you know
there's not a set of published standards
or even anything
that the developers can look at so one
one way in potentially is smart on fire
which is
a standard that allows communication of
healthcare data between different
systems
and it's standardized and i it
it does depend on it being implemented
in the ehr but
as so as a information blocking
um there's a the cures act
21st century tears act which which
passed
mandates sharing of information between
healthcare information systems so so
that eventually it seems like
this will be a way for um free and open
source software to get
essentially hook into the existing
clinical information systems
so yeah there's a large challenges to
implementing any sort of new
new software package
and this uh everything's ready to come
tumbling down
at any point so you know people can be
very conservative about
about using new software in large
institutions
so thanks for your time um
i i hope that uh we have some
some discussion that that might provide
some insight about this topic if anyone
has any particular experience with any
of these tools i'd love to hear about
it any questions for me or
clarifications about
anything we talked about are also
welcome
yeah thanks thanks eric nice
presentation actually um
you gave a very good talk you've
presented the paper well i i might have
at the beginning thrown in a slide just
so people
um can kind of understand a little bit
about info buttons which are really
meant to um you know kind of marry
um clinical data to information
resources
many of us um or some of us anyways know
jim cimino
who kind of developed this notion back
in the 1990s
and info buttons work great when you
have
structured data on each side so you may
have like an icd-9 or 10 code or snomed
code in the ehr
and that can get translated to like a
mesh term
you know to access um the literature and
that's
that's kind of the focus of what info
button has tried to do
um so there it's a lot more challenging
as i think with these
um genomics resources that
that may not be as well structured or
may not be as well structured
in the kinds of terminology systems that
are used in
um clinical systems and then one other
large question i want to take up all the
time
um you know it really is a form of
search
and and i think a big unanswered
question is um
um is is it better to try to anticipate
the user search by putting this button
and linking them to something
or um just giving them a search box and
letting them have at it
i don't know if you have any um thoughts
on that and then we can open it up to
the rest of the
group
um so excellent excellent point
uh so i i like having
you know personally my personal thoughts
are that having the buttons
is is excellent when they are
uh when they're relevant and
you know because if i want to know
something
there's usually a search box i can find
but but the but
the suggestion that you know here's more
information
uh is always is often appreciated i mean
sometimes i'm not going to go all the
way to a search box but if i see the
button there
um it's i'm going to think of a question
that i want answered
so i think there's definitely value in
that approach
and i guess i'll just say one other
thing you know you also raise the
question of of
evidence and
you know again it's an issue of what is
um
relevant well not relevant isn't a good
word you know what what's applicable in
the clinical setting
um you know some animal study or tissue
culture study might be great
um as a you know potential for some
um genomic therapy um
but you know obviously if a clinician is
going to use it it'll need to
it will need to have been tested in some
sort of
clinical trial kind of setting
right so yeah i have
essentially no experience with genetic
or genomic medicine in my clinical
practice
um but uh i i
do i do
want um evidence
cited when i um am
taking recommendations from a computer
um
so one thing for example is you know
i do a lot of uh healthcare maintenance
as a family doctor
so you know there's recommendations
from the hr this person needs uh like
this vaccine
or this screening study or whatever it
may be
and and oftentimes these things are
really straightforward and it's just
like if you're over this age you know
you're
you're over 65 you get a a pneumonia
shot for example
um but but then you know a lot of the
recommendations are more
nuanced than that so you know if you
are say a a cigarette smoker
then you should be vaccinated with
the pneumonia shot at at any age
you don't have to wait until 65. so
you know oftentimes an ehr will
recommend a pneumonia shot
for somebody but you know it's just a
it's just a list of it just
recommendations for this patient nevony
shot
um you know and as a as a
as a physician i i want to know
you know why right i can i can go
through a big list of questions with any
particular patient you know maybe this
is a new person i've never met them
before
to try to figure out why the system is
flagging them as
needing an ammonia shot but i mean
that's the perfect place for
an info button to say
you know this patient is
recommended for this because of this
reason and this is
you know why why this is important and
i mean that would immediately
allow me to feel comfortable you know
ordering that for them without taking
more than a
you know probably 10 seconds
see i saw something in the chat there
all right so vishnu's point is that
the amount of genomic information
available currently
is hugely greater than the amount of
actionable genomic information and
that's a really good point
um because yeah when i'm
if i'm busy seeing a bunch of patients
uh
you know if there's an info button i
might have
i might get the chance to to learn
something i'm definitely not going to go
out and
um do a complicated literature search
in the middle of a clinic day but
uh i but i would click on a button and
then
so not not sure if the gap between
theory and action is reduced
that much um
yeah i guess that's an open question
so this is vishnu so one you know apart
from the actual
incorporation of genomic information i
think
you know one thing that this this paper
really got me thinking about was
how do you kind of incorporate um open
source software
into a commercial ehr environment that
exists in most institutions right and
i think two kind of take-home messages
as as you said eric just because it's
it's so called free and open source
is neither necessarily free nor open
source in its entirety right
and even you know even some of the
obvious open source software that's used
in healthcare
are often associated with very
significant implementation and
maintenance costs
um and so so there is no free lunch you
know in many cases
in in in the healthcare application of
the software
the real tricky you know kind of
challenging part is
if you think of an organization like
ohsu that has been part of a commercial
ehr vendor ecosystem for
you know well more than a decade how do
you incorporate
any kind of advancement in open source
technology and resources
and integrated in a relatively seamless
fashion into say an epic shop or a
center shop or a meditek shop
that's pretty challenging without having
to resort to you know
coming out of the electronic health
record or
so i would be really actually kind of
curious as to
you know what folks who are more
knowledgeable about this than i am think
about incorporating info buttons into
commercial ehrs
that integrate that integrate into open
source
software
so row heat has an interesting point
um thinking about genomes in a clinical
context
isn't taught yet in medical schools when
presenting patients there's no section
for genes after your micro portion of
your hbi
so from a generational standpoint as
genomic information becomes clinically
useful demand for info buttons
will reach a more critical mass
when future doctors are accustomed to
genetic info and
that that is a is a good point and i
believe that
um that was more or less cited
let me see here i'll go ahead and pull
the
the slides up again
if we go to the
responses
there we go
so yeah the
mission critical use case basically um
you know as as this stuff is useful and
as it's expected to be needed you know
there's going to be a clear
a clear use case which will probably
address
lack lack of demand for this stuff and
that's going to take
time so i'm
i'm trying to figure out which side of
the generational divide i'm on
um it was meant to be a joke um
but um you know i mean there there's
really layers of issues here i
i mean to a little bit reiterating what
i had said before um
you know there are some kind of
practical implementation issues um
many of you spend more time tooling
around inside of epic than i do but i
i know that the info the
info button is an hl7 standard and i
believe it's implemented in
epic um but then you get into the
question
of um of of you know how much do you
um want to let um you know informatics
people
tool around inside of of epic but but i
think the larger
question actually gets to um rohit's
point
um which is that um
there you know where there is becoming
more and more actionable genomic
information
and clinical care um but you know the
the question is um you know what's
actionable
um what um you know what's the best way
to get
people to that information um
um you know what is the level of
evidence you know is it
something that you know is a sort of um
inferential kind of pathway that you
took
with three levels of re of redirection
to get to
you know or something that was starting
a clinical trial
i i mean i actually have to say
especially for those of you who are
looking for um these thesis and
dissertation projects you know this
whole
notion of of how we um implement this
complex genomics
in a clinical setting is is a real ripe
um
area and um um you know would be
because we are learning more and there
is more actionable information
but it's also um you know how do we boil
that down to
clinical decisions that that get made
and and you know probably the most
area where it's most advanced is in
cancer with molecular targeted therapies
and so forth
um but even even those and i mean there
are some people
um who are building clinical decision
support systems for
those sorts of things um but you know
again
the question is you know can you boil
can you boil
the facts down to some algorithmic
pathway to take
or do you really need um you know a
clinical expert
on the patient and a you know kind of a
sub-specialist who knows that area to
really
make that kind of decision um you know
as opposed to
a clinician clicking on a button you
know it's a little different than a you
know drug drug interaction warning
um you know which is is pretty um
stereotypical
these are probably a lot more complex
decisions that that would need to be
made
so i have a question for you eric and
also possibly for bill i mean one of the
you know the main reason that they kind
of point as a barrier is
is the lack of institutional priority
and and the lack of demand
mostly the lack of institutional
priority and then when they actually in
the discussion section when they talk
about
it it's a little bit sketchy right i
mean they say we need to have a
physician champion
and then we need to figure something
else out it's the essence of
of of that discussion section so i would
be really curious
as you know what what are these
you know how do we actually make you
know the the this kind of
i mean clearly we understand the value
of it as information
how do we make this kind of effort and
institutional priority within our
clinical organizations
are there other things that you know we
can do apart from just you know
identifying physician champions and
reaching out to leadership
um well
i mean with with any of these things
it's it's the specific
the very specific use case you know the
like the word
picture you know is there i mean is
there a real
uh is there a real example of of um
you know a an improved outcome for a
specific person
based on uh you know genomic information
and that that you know was accessed by a
a typical like a primary care doctor
or you know somebody you know not an
ultra specialist and you know and then
do you have an example of a
of a patient that uh you know
couldn't or had was that this would have
applied to but but they didn't receive a
an intervention because their clinician
didn't
didn't know this information and i mean
that that's the kind of like
you know it paints a picture and it it
tells a story about
a person a person's life and and
you know that without that kind of
example
um you know i'm not sure how you
how you get there from here
you know there there are definite
examples um and
actually i'm not the expert so if
there's anyone um
who uh correct me if i'm wrong about
things but you know for example there
um you know there's certain types of
lung cancer i think small cell carcinoma
where p where patients who have a
specific gene in their
gene variant in their tumor um respond
well to a chemotherapy agent that other
people don't respond to at all
um some of the you know it's the whole
precision medicine paradigm of really
um um you know identifying the molecular
pathways and
and drugs that are effective against
them that you know again to me
you know the question is is whether you
could boil
those situations down to something for
which an
info button you know would be helpful uh
helpful you know i think you know the
original vision of info buttons was that
um
you know you would have a patient with
um
diabetes and and you would
be looking at um a potential drug to
prescribe
and you know you click on it to you know
pull up information about that drug
related to diabetes
um but those are really broad topics
um you know as opposed to something like
a very narrow
um you know targeted therapy
so um um you know that and
that that's the situation that getting
that information
um you know of course again you know how
many times is the
you know primary care doc going to be
making a treatment decision on
chemotherapy on a cancer patient
um uncommon um
so you know so i guess another question
you know i would have you know about
this study is
is i mean genomic medicine really good
use case for info buttons it may be
i i don't want to dismiss it out of hand
but um
you know if you think of some of the
kind of
decisions that get made in treating
patients
with um you know conditions that are
amenable
to to knowing their their genome variant
um you know who who's going to use that
kind of information
right and right now it's it's you know
the specialists right and
oncologists you know do they do they
need an info button
to to explain the paradigm of selecting
their
their uh you know their treatment no
they generally don't and and
they're going to be reading more
detailed information
than probably is going to just come up
in an info button they're already
already aware of the issue um rohit
mentioned something about
ssri medications and that's a that's a
great
uh idea i mean i would love it if i had
some guidance
on what kind of ssri to choose
you know because i prescribe a
significant amount of those
and you know generally it's like well
what does the patient
feel like they want to do or you know
you just kind of
uh roll the dice with basically
the consensus is that this ssri has is
more activating in this one
you know and but there's not a bunch of
evidence on that um but but yeah i think
and as as vishnu mentioned i think that
you know we just don't have
genetic uh we don't have information
about our patient's genetics
generally i mean like um
you know aloperinol for example is going
to cause
like stevens johnson syndrome in a
certain number of people and
you might want to prescribe that for
gout but but you're not going to
you're not going to test them um first
if you're you know particularly this
astute you might
mention to the patient hey if you get uh
you know your skin starts to fall off
after you take this medicine
please stop um but
but you know when when are we gonna have
that kind of information about people
and if
you know if they if we're talking about
a cancer treatment yeah people are going
to
be happy to have their genetics tested
or
whatever the case may be to to help them
survive but
you know if it's just gout or whatever
we're not going to have it beforehand
and we're not going to wait to get it
before we treat them i mean eric in an
ideal environment at some point in the
future i assume that
genomic information will be incorporated
enough to have a drug genomic
interaction checker for every time you
prescribe something right so
i would love that that reality where
it's not that i have to actively try and
order a test in order to find the
genomic stuff so
you know everyone's everyone's kind of
sequenced into the ehr
and it's automatically being kind of
added to that
to that list and it's also depending on
you know
for example if i you know if i take care
of generations or families if all their
genomic
information can be integrated because
the parent had a higher risk of not you
know had a
autosomal dominant disease i can start
thinking about you know it just becomes
interesting
i want to get back to the point though
after i read this this paper you know
one of the things that i thought of
was how do i make an roi argument for
this right i mean how do i kind of sell
this from an roi perspective
to an institution and i didn't get there
right i mean i couldn't
and and the depressing thought that i
had was you know once there is
a patient harm that occurs because of a
delayed diagnosis or a delayed you know
response to identifying genomic
information that was already in the
chart
that's when you know organizations may
probably sit up and take notice um
that that there's a need to actually do
this because otherwise we're going to
get sued
but there really isn't a a good roi
response and i see em's comment on
on on chat that the the false aspect of
discussion is at best secondary to the
goals
that i'm hearing as priorities and it's
really so funny that you spent all this
time talking about stuff
but the real kind of focus of the paper
was on the force aspect right
and um it's it's pretty remarkable that
we're
we're kind of deviated from that primary
topic yeah you know they they
specifically mention that in their
objectives
but and and i'm not entirely familiar
but i don't know
how many other you know how many
commercial alternatives
are there to you know info buttons for
genetics and genomics
research is that is that a is that
really significant
i mean the the the whole product itself
you know is like a new thing like yes
yes
they're and they they're free and open
source these
in general but that's not the barrier
right and and when they talked about the
barriers to implementation
they weren't specific i mean first of
all they weren't specific to
genetics and genomics they weren't
specific to free and open source i mean
they
it came up again and again you know
somebody has to clearly
elucidate the use case and communicate
why it's useful
in you know basically like uh
you know ceo terms to to people to get
this stuff to be adopted and that has
that really does have nothing to do with
with open source or
you know that's that's like a a basic
tenet of
of institutional change yeah but
remember too though that um you know
info buttons
you know is really just a standard a
standard way of basically
taking some clinical data out of the ehr
and sending it to
basically a search engine um or
or to a knowledge resource that's
structured enough where you would know
the point and then basically
um sending that back and you know again
some of you
some of you who are here spend more time
inside i don't know my understanding is
that epic
implements info buttons you know it is
an hl7 standard i don't know how well
but but you know it's one thing to have
this
api basically that lets you exchange
information back and forth but then it's
another thing
to be able to figure out you know what
is the right data to put there
where on the screen do you put it you
know with the workflow and then then on
the other side on the knowledge resource
you know do you have access to it
you know some things like pubmed are
free um
other things um you know like up to date
well i i guess ohsu has a license to it
but
those sorts of things cost money um
and and then these genomics resources um
some of them are pretty fairly well
structured but um
they may not be structured in a way that
that is um
that aligns well with um you know snomed
or icd-10 codes things like that
let me actually ask the uh the audience
um
does um does epic um support
um info buttons i mean if ohsu
if itg gave you the blessing could you
connect
uh you know a say a lab ordering screen
to some lab resource yeah they call it
active guidelines
that's the epic language for it okay and
commercial third parties have already
done exactly what
you said bill like you know connector
labs so for example um
clinic he is el saviour's product um
they do exactly that mm-hmm
what product is that vishnu uh lcvs
clinique
cli and i k e y for market state
oh cl clinical key is that it yeah
it's clinical key yeah okay
epic loves to change the names of the
you know just like they call clinical
decision support best practice alerts
just to confuse people
any other comments questions out there
yeah this uh you know this is a great
paper because it really
you know brings out a lot of um issues
um you know in in informatics
and not just like implementation issues
but but
you know issues around you know the ehr
and
who can do what with it and accessing
more
free and open resources and so forth so
well okay i'm sorry someone say
something oh i just said yeah i
i i agree i kind of it it makes for an
interesting discussion because it goes
from
clinical practice all the way up to like
you know how do you
how do you sell an institution on
implementing a
huge project and what's the mechanics of
that so
yeah good okay well um thanks everyone
for attending today
i agree it was great discussion and um
um i guess as long
as i have people's attention before they
leave um
so we have uh um well we have a bunch of
talks coming up some not at the regular
times because of
thesis and dissertation defenses and
things like that
we do have an outside speaker next uh
week uh dr
kendrick cato from columbia university
and then also um um everyone is welcome
to virtual commencement whether you're
graduating or not
um the invitation um uh just went out
and um um it'll be great uh to see
people at commencement uh not not as
much fun as being there in person
in your regalia and all that but um it
will still be fun
nonetheless okay take care everyone good
to see you all